[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week-end
voici les titres de ce vendredi 16 avril
le classement a été dévoilé il fait
plutôt bon vivre dans les yvelines 25
cités font partie des 500 villes et
douze communes des 500 villages où il
est agréable d'habiter réaction des
maires de montigny le bretonneux et
versailles est également pourquoi le
gouvernement n'at-il pas reporter les
élections régionales et départementales
mais seulement décalée d'une semaine
réponse avec notre invité est
jean-pierre camby professeur en droit
constitutionnel
associé à l'université versailles saint
quentin car c'est bien une question de
droit enfin comme chaque semaine et même
confiné célia agathe son go vous
proposera à ses idées sorties et loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fait-il bon vivre dans les villes et
villages de france c'est la question que
pose le palmarès de villes et villages
pour la seconde année consécutive
l'association juge les 34 1837 communes
françaises dimanche dernier le journal
du dimanche a publié les résultats parmi
les 500 villes 25 cités yvelinoise et
saint-quentinoise ont fait le point avec
mélanie poké bixente mais insatisfait
ban nicolas landry et astrid bergère
pour refus d'enlever large accord c'est
très sympa hein
gdj meubles tranquille ya toujours des
trucs à faire
on est quand même le cadre de la
campagne aussi l'agitation de la ville
le côté nature résidentiel
avec beaucoup d espaces verts les
ennemis montant aiment leur commune
qu'ils soient habitants commerçants
ce qui explique peut-être la 219e place
au classement de l'association villes et
villages ça nous conforte par rapport
aux choix politiques qui sont menées
depuis très longtemps a menti puisque on
voit que ceux ci sont régulièrement
mises en avant sur sur nos choix en
aménagement des différents quartiers
le fait d'avoir des bâtiments à taille
humaine d'avoir de la mixité
fonctionnelle ceci à dire chaque année
quartier d'avoir une grande place aux
espaces verts de faire aussi de grands
efforts à maintenir de sécurité et
quatre communes saint quentinois sont
présentes dans ce classement
trapé la première avec le sens 91e rang
25 des livres chinois sont distingués la
première versailles se classent 49e on
n'a pas le laden si on n'a pas les
montagnes à côté c'est vrai à châteaulin
à parc extraordinaire c'est déjà un
atout je pense que ce qui jouer pour
nous c'était la qualité d'enseignement
qui très connue à cette personne je
pense aussi que c'est une ville
relativement sûre santé éducation ou
encore solidarité 183 critères ont
permis de classer les 34 mais le
communes françaises
les loges en josas ont cette année à la
9e place dans le palmarès des villes de
moins de 2000 habitants
l'autre actualité cette semaine c'est le
report des élections départementales et
régionales pour parler de ce sujet nous
accueillons en visioconférence avec nous
jean pierre camby bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes donc professeur en droit
constitutionnel
associé à l'université versailles saint
quentin à paris saclay tout d'abord les
élections devaient se tenir les 13 et 20
juin prochains
le gouvernement a choisi de maintenir au
mois de juin après un vote consultatif
des maires des députés mais également
des sénateurs mais de les décaler d'une
semaine les 20 et 27 juin prochains
alors si les élus ont été consultés nous
avons également posé la question aux
yvelinois
vous voyez le sondage qui va s'afficher
sur votre écran
à la question êtes vous pour ou contre
ce report des élections les yvelinois
ont répondu pour à 53% et contre à 47%
un résultat plutôt équilibré donc
jean-pierre camby pourquoi le
gouvernement n'at-il pas plus décalé ces
élections plutôt que pourquoi une
semaine seulement finalement il faut
signaler qu'il vient lui un premier
report entérinée par une loi car c'est
la loi qui doit décider du report
éventuel d'une échéance électorale
et en l'espèce le gouvernement a choisi
de respecter la loi qui a été votée le
22 février dernier pour qu'un nouveau
report soit justifiée il faudrait un
motif impérieux d'intérêt général qui
ici ne se prouve pas vraiment puisque il
faudrait miser sur une nouvelle
dégradation de la situation sanitaire
ceux qui actuellement heureusement n'est
pas envisageable
par conséquent c'est un décret qui fixe
la date concrète des élections le
gouvernement a simplement choisi de
décaler d'une semaine par rapport à ce
qu'il avait avancé alors la situation
sanitaire il faudrait qu'elle se dégrade
pour c'est ce que vous dites pour que
les élections soient vraiment reporter
on va dire de plusieurs mois quelles
sont les circonstances les autres
circonstances qui obligerait un report
de ce vote
il faudrait des circonstances
exceptionnelles le principe de la
démocratie c'est que les électeurs sont
appelés à voter à échéances régulières
et qu'on ne peut troubler ses espérances
pétrolière une fois encore que pour un
motif suffisamment grave des
circonstances exceptionnelles
il faudrait par exemple qu à la date
prévue
un nouveau confinement générale et
absolue soit décidée c'est pour ça vous
pensez que le gouvernement maintient
cette date du 3 mai pour le
déconfinement par étapes
le gouvernement ne peut pas faire
autrement que de le tenir compte de ce
pont calendrier général pour fixer le
calendrier des élections
on peut ajouter à cela que la loi
prévoit la vie un comité de
scientifiques et que l'avis de ce comité
scientifique a été que les élections
pouvaient se tenir sous certaines
conditions sanitaires
pour l'instant les conditions sont
remplies
justement quelle organisation pour ses
futures élections
est ce que le vote à distance comme aux
états unis on a beaucoup entendu parler
avec les présidentielles américaines
devraient être privilégiés quelle
organisation selon vous pour ces
élections pour privilégier un vote à
distance
il faudrait d'une part des modifications
législatives et notre pas un délai
technique suffisant ces conditions ne
sont pas respectées il faut ajouter
qu'en france on vote à l'urne et que le
gouvernement a tout fait pour faciliter
l'expression du vote par procuration
ont notamment en prévoyant deux
procurations possible ce qui n'était pas
le cas avant 2020 est également en
prévoyant que l'on peut dématérialiser
l'envoi des procurations
tout est fait pour que les citoyens
puissent y participer à cette échéance
y compris sur l'organisation des bureaux
trucks justement cette organisation des
bureaux de vote le gouvernement envisage
de vacciner l'ensemble des assesseurs
des personnels qui tiendront ces bureaux
de vote
c'est faisable selon vous justement à
l'échéance du 20 juin prochain c'est ce
que le comité des scientifiques a
demandé ce n'est sans doute pas faisable
le gouvernement a quand même aménager
les bureaux de vote de manière à ce
qu'ils aient nié par exemple qu'un
président pour les deux bureaux
régionales et départementales et la même
chose au niveau des secrétaires des
bureaux un seul secrétaire pour les deux
scrutins
c'est déjà beaucoup il est souhaitable
que le maximum de personnes électeurs ou
membres des bureaux soient vaccinés si
tel n'est pas le cas
eh bien il n'y a pas plus de risques
objectif à aller voter car se rendre par
exemple dans son supermarché où l'appât
files d'attentes peut-être plus longue
dernière question jean-pierre cambi la
peur des conditions sanitaires une
élection qui ne passionne pas les foules
vous dites à l'instant qui a pas plus de
raisons d'aller voter que de aller au
supermarché
est ce que vous avez peur quand même
d'une probable très forte abstention
est-ce que ça poserait pas non plus un
problème démocratique cette abstention
naturellement moins une élection est
acquise avec une base une assiette
suffisante
plus elle est fragile mais j'observe par
exemple que
sept français sur dix se sont abstenus
pour le référendum sur le quinquennat
qui a été une révision constitutionnelle
importante en septembre 2000
il n'empêche que cette réforme s'est
appliqué
classiquement pour ces élections
régionales et départementales
le taux d'abstention plus fort qu'il ne
l'est pour les municipales ou pour les
élections de débuter ou naturellement
pour l'élection présidentielle
mais on peut aussi considérer que les
français dans le contexte actuel ont
fortement envie de s'impliquer dans
l'élection
ce qui est évidemment souhaitable et
même respectable
vous savez un niveau d'abstention ne
dépense jamais une condition sanitaire
aux techniques il dépend exclusivement
de l'envié qu'ont les électeurs de
s'exprimer
eh bien c'est ce que nous verrons les 20
et 27 juin prochains pour ces élections
départementales et régionales
merci jean pierre camby d'avoir été avec
nous pour cette suite week-end et je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur en
droit constitutionnel associé à
l'université versailles saint quentin
paris saclay après une semaine bien
chargée quoi de mieux aussi que de se
détendre le week-end avec le confinement
et comme chaque vendredi s'il y avait
tsongo vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous commençons avec une
bonne nouvelle pour les majeurs de
l'agglomération gps et au la piscine de
mignot à poissy a rouvert ses portes
depuis samedi 27 mars
les habitués étaient ravis de retrouver
le bassin extérieur le montage de
sandrine fontaine
je suis ravie je me demande même si chez
encore nager tellement ça fait longtemps
que je peux aller à la piscine premiers
plongeons depuis six mois
les habitués de la piscine de mignot à
poissy retrouve le bassin extérieur
considérée comme un équipement de plein
air oui ça fait beaucoup de bien on est
super contents que soient rouverts ouais
effectivement j'attendais ça qu'un
patient je regarde je check est
régulièrement le site et des ucsa a été
rouvert j'ai repris tu tapes ici n'est
normalement qu'un de les piscines seront
pratiquement tout permet enfin de toutes
celles qui n'ont pas de bassins
extérieurs
donc on attendait que ça très contents
se faisait depuis six mois que ça allait
fermer
voilà ça fait du bien au mental c'est
entre 1h15 et une heure et demie pour
pour le plaisir
ce sont seulement les nageurs de plus de
12 ans qui sont autorisés à venir
trois créneaux horaires sont possibles
chacun pouvant accueillir 84 personnes
maximum
mais c'est de fluidifier aussi un petit
peu l'arrivée des clients c'est vrai que
si on avait une ouverture publique 2010
jusqu'à 18h30 la problèmatique ondra
qu'on avait c'est peut-être un afflux de
personnes entre midi et 14 heures et
plus forcément grand monde en plein
milieu d'après-midi et puisqu'on passe
aussi en réservation recommandée
les personnes voit très bien le taux de
remplissage qu'on peut avoir par créneau
masque désinfection des mains est quasi
individuelle obligatoire
fléchage et code couleur pour les
entrées/sorties douche savonnée avant
d'aller dans l'eau quand protocoles
sanitaires strictes a été établi ce soit
aussi trois couloirs au lieu de 6 pour
éviter les croisements
on essaie de tourner à peu près
vingtaine de personnes parlent une dose
sachant que c'est un bassin de 50 mètres
donc ça laisse beaucoup de place à
partir de mai la jauge devraient être
augmentés à 200 personnes maximum
la pataugeoire quand elle ouvrira au
mois de juin si les conditions saines
était en le permettent
jusqu'au dimanche 25 avril la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet organise une
chasse au lapin virtuel tous les jours à
16h sur leur page facebook vous pourrez
visionner le portrait d'un acteur de la
ferme qui raconte son travail
le but pour les enfants retrouvez le la
part de bach caché dans la vidéo les
explications de ce jeu dans l'interview
express avec frédéric brieuc le
responsable des animations à la bergerie
nationale
pendant les 16 jours des vacances à 16
heures une nouvelle vidéo est postée sur
le compte facebook de la bergerie qui
présente un des acteurs de
l'exploitation agricole qu'il soit
animateurs ou dans la production qui se
présentent entre une minute et 2 et 2
minutes et dans le décor qui lui est
dédié on y trouve on retrouve le petit
lapin voyageurs de cacher oui d'été de
ces cette vidéo c'est vraiment mettre en
avant le projet de l'exploitation qui
est un projet orienté sur une
agriculture très respectueuse de
l'animal le bien-être animal et de
l'environnement puisque ça s'appelle
l'agroécologie donc chaque voilà on a
orienté les vidéos pour que chaque
personne finalement va parler d'un
dernier élément un des collègues va
plutôt parler du bien-être animal d'un
autre sur l'autonomie alimentaire
quelqu'un d'autre sur les circuits
courts
les témoignages sont déjà sympathique de
voir qu'ils sont contents de voir qu'on
que finalement la vie continue à la
bergerie malgré tout finalement les gens
sont saïd est là le plus possible en
direct mais on est beaucoup beaucoup
suivi plus tôt après finalement les gens
peuvent retrouver les vidéos les
facebook live ensuite et c'est vraiment
le point fort finalement de cette
méthode virtuel c'est de finalement de
pouvoir toucher des gens qu'on touchera
peut-être pas et qui profitent de des
vidéos ludiques et éducatives encore
longtemps après avec le confinement nous
cherchons des balades à faire à moins de
10 kilomètres et cela tombe bien puisque
le domaine de dampierre rouvre son parc
les visiteurs auront accès aux 90
hectares de verdure avec bixente n'ai
rien senti steban nous nous sommes
rendus au domaine regarder
[Musique]
nous sommes au coeur du domaine de
dampierre en yvelines le parc de 90
hectares a rouvert samedi 27 mars pour
l'occasion 25 mille bulbes ont été
plantés dans le jardin anglais parce
qu'elle est un bon jour bonjour vous
êtes le directeur du domaine
une nouvelle aire de jeu a été ouverte
de quoi était le composent et oui pour
agrémenter la visite
du public dans nos 90 hectares il y
avait le parc floral avec tous et merci
c'est ces gens qui essaient tudip qui
ont été plantés comme vous disiez mais
il ya également au delà dans une zone
humide une aire de jeu naturel qui a été
réalisé à la demande en fait du public
depuis deux ans maintenant que nous
sommes ouverts
le public me trouvais qu'il manquait des
aides pour les enfants et donc nous
avions installé des aires de pique nique
mais au delà tout autour et bien nous
avons reconstitué avec des graminées
labyrinthe alors les graminées viennent
des plantes et donc tout ça ça va
pousser au delà il ya des cabanes en
osier qui ont été plantés
donc c'est vraiment des mes plans de
milieu humide parce qu'on a voulu
respecter le site
nous sommes un site classé donc on
essaie de trouver des
des éléments qui soit le plus naturel
possible et on a complété lançant par un
parcours en poutres de bois posée
au sol et puis d
bille de bois sur laquelle les enfants
quand quant à lui quand il découvre ça
ils s'amusent à sauter d'une vie à
l'autre et la pression de prendre de la
hauteur et d'évoluer au milieu des
arbres
c'est très sain var le jardin anglais
aussi lui est ouvert là on est mi avril
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir alors la mi
avril on est à la fin des narcisses et
des gens qui les tulipes commence depuis
quelques jours a vraiment à prendre
toutes leurs
leur ampleur et à cette plantation de
tulipes a été étudié par nos jardiniers
pour qu'on ait des fleurs jusqu'au 15
mai puisque on s'est dit on va sortir de
l'hiver qui déjà était morose
naturellement et puis ensuite avec cet
épisode de confinement on s'est dit il
faut que le public qu'ils trouvent un
intérêt un attrait pardon à venir
découvrir et à avoir du plaisir à
découvrir notre jardin et donc on a des
petits livres qui vont continuer à
fleurir au fur et à mesure des semaines
pour aller jusqu'au 15 mai après le 15
mai bien après ce sont les feuilles aux
arts dans ce sont les chaînes et les
promenades 2 ombragée qui prendront le
relais vous aviez aussi des calèches on
pouvait visiter le domaine en calèche
est ce que c'est toujours possible alors
dans le cas de
l'application de
des règles sanitaires nous avons
maintenu dans un nombre limité les
promenades de calèche par contre nous
avons arrêté l'exploitation des rosalies
et
des golfs et des voiturettes électriques
parce qu'il fallait engager une
procédure de désaffection des calèches
c'est plus facile à désinfecter les
distances sociales sont mise puisqu'on a
limité le nombre et du coup elle tout le
monde et c'est aussi là aussi un grand
succès parce que me suis dit c'est
peut-être pas évident de d'ouvrir dans
la perle de confinement dans un rayon de
10 kilomètres et on a de fortes demandes
pour découvrir là on sort des jardins et
là on rentre dans le parc forestier
impact fort ici c'est 400 hectares on ne
découvre pas l'ensemble des 400 hectares
avec la calèche
mais on en découvre deux mois une
centaine supplémentaire donc sans plus
les 90 hectares de jardin si vous passez
une journée à dampierre vous découvrez
200 hectares de nature
en ce moment les listings les bébés sans
qu'ils sont en train d'être les enfants
commencent à changer leurs robes des
découvertes sans cesse
dans la forêt comme dans les jardins
justement vous disiez avec le
confinement s'est limité à 10 km
finalement ce sont des visiteurs locaux
qui viennent ici ils viennent me re
découvrir peut-être ce jardin alors la
grande surprise pour nous c'est qu'en
fait ils viennent de redécouvrir pour
certains mais j'aime surtout découvrir
c'est quelque chose qui m'a un peu
surpris le jour de l'ouverture
les gens qui sont venus nous voir en
disant on vient de voisins-le-bretonneux
on ne connaissait pas dampierre
ils l'ont eue parce qu'on a fait une pub
dans un journal local et du coup ils
sont ils ont vraiment découvert
aujourd'hui mais on va parler de ce parc
autour de nous parce que on sait à nos
portes
c'est dans le rayon des 10 km et on ne
connaît pas et donc au secours nous en
interne ça nous permet de permis de
mener une réflexion et donc du coup on
est en train de fumer de commandos
cibler le public au sein de ce rayon de
10 km pour montrer aux gens dans les
sens donnez-vous kilomètres on a quand
même cinq cent mille habitants
on n'imaginait pas du château de
vaux-le-vicomte surtout de oui contre
reste fermé puisqu'il n'y a personne au
tour nous les avons une agglomération
saint quentin en yvelines avec près de
cinq cent mille habitants qui sont dans
le rayon des 10 km et donc c'est pour
nous l'occasion de ses rayons de 10 km
est bien de valoriser de faire de créer
de la notoriété de dampierre et de faire
une nouvelle activité pour des gens qui
ne connaissaient pas trésor et la merci
beaucoup pascal thévard d'avoir et les
autres invités
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose de partir ce week-end à la
chasse aux oeufs dans deux lieux
différents
d'abord au coeur du parc municipal de
trappes samedi 17 avril de 10 heures à
18 heures la ville organise pour les
enfants une grande chasse aux oeufs de
pâques
un jeu de piste grandeur nature
d'environ une heure avec à la clé des
oeufs en chocolat et puis le château de
breteuil à choisel cachera lui aussi des
oeufs dans son parc dimanche 18 avril
les enfants pourront entre 10h et 17h
venir les trouver et le 7-8 week-end de
continuer avec eléonore pour parler de
l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le reste de l'actualité de la semaine
c'est justin brasier qui nous le résume
en 78 secondes les lieux culturels sont
dans l'attenté d'une réponse définitive
pour redémarrer la machine ce jeudi le
porte parole du gouvernement a confirmé
aux échos une ouverture partielle a
laminé les musées pourraient être les
premiers à rouvrir leurs portes se
tester soi même au kobus 19 c'est
désormais possible depuis lundi la vente
des autotests est autorisée en pharmacie
l'arrêté du ministère a été publié
dimanche au journal officiel
plusieurs pharmacies yvelinoise ne sont
pas encore approvisionnées les
agriculteurs illinois n'ont pas été
épargné par le gel qui a touché
l'ensemble du pays les températures
négatives tardif qui ont causé de
nombreux dégâts dans les exploitations
un impact qui s'explique par un choc
thermique après le reportage de
complément d'enquêté sur l'entretien
atos révélant la présence de cancer du
cerveau parmi le personnel
la mairie des clayes-sous-bois contacter
la rs pour mesurer l'exposition aux
ondes électromagnétiques dans la ville
des mesures qui se sont avérées en
dessous des normes
la piscine de mignot a rouvert à poissy
après presque six mois de fermeture le
bassin extérieur est de nouveau
accessible protocole sanitaire oblige
une jauge maximale de nageurs et des
créneaux ont été mis en place
[Musique]
pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end votre
rendez vous comme chaque semaine en
partenariat avec les surligneurs ce
collectif qui décrypte les déclarations
des personnalités publiques et
politiques on écoute vincent couronne
docteur en droit à l'université
versailles saint quentin et fondateur
des sciences l'ignorent
l'association turco européennes milica
russe a obtenu un permis de construire
pour une école située à albertville
alors qu'elle a refusé de signer la
nouvelle charte des principes pour
l'islam de france
le député les républicains guillaume
pelletier demande alors au gouvernement
de dissoudre cette association pour
cette raison on peut effectivement
dissoudre une association c'est prévu
par le code de la sécurité intérieure
mais c'est là que guillaume lepennetier
se trompe on ne peut dissoudre que les
associations liées à des actes de
terrorisme ou qui incitent à la
discrimination à la haine voire à la
violence c'est ce qui est arrivé au
collectif contre l'islamophobie en
france le ccf qui a été dissous fin 2020
ou à génération identitaire plus
récemment dissoute 1 en mars 2021 à
droite
cette idée n'est pas nouvelle déjà en
2017 françois fillon ont réclamé la
dissolution de toute association qui se
réclament du salafisme
or si on commence à dissoudre des
associations pour motifs politiques ou
idéologiques
on met le doigt dans un engrenage
infernal un gouvernement de gauche
pourraient ainsi dissoudre une
association seulement parce qu'elle est
trop à droite à son goût il est toujours
facile de proposer dans l'émotion et
l'indignation des mesures qui paraissent
être de bon sens pour ses électeurs mais
un responsable politique ne doit jamais
oublier qu'il ne fait pas des lois
seulement pour son parti mais aussi pour
l'opposition qui demain pourrait être
majoritaire et pourrait bien retourner
sa loi contre lui
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 week-end
merci de l'avoir suivi et même confiné
passé une excellente soirée et un
excellent week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]